o ano de 2015 marca 25 anos do
funcionamento do telescópio rabo que é
considerado um dos equipamentos mais
importantes no avanço da ciência
aqui nós vemos nas fotos do hubble e é
interessante notar que assim que ele foi
lançado
houve um erro um erro no espelho um
problema bastante conhecido e esse
problema fez com que o rambo virá até
certo sentido chacota na empresa
americana e houve vários altos e baixos
em todo o projeto mas um problema que é
relativamente pouco conhecido que também
aconteceu com esse telescópio foi antes
da primeira foto
e esse problema foi na abertura do
painel
vocês estão vendo aí o desafio um
entender os sensores
você imagina que um painel solar é para
as espaçonaves para as que estão em
órbitas tanto órbitas baixas com obras
mais distantes
a fonte de energia e no lançamento da
espaçonave um sensor indicou que um
painel não poderia ser aberto
com isso toda missão toda a espaçonave
ia ser colocada em risco
nesse momento os cientistas tiveram a
decisão manter aquele sinal ou sobrepuja
o sinal passar um sinal ampliar os
limites desse sinal do sensor
felizmente eles tomaram a segunda
decisão e ampliaram os limites do sinal
de sensores
nosso primeiro desafio aqui é entender a
complexidade e ao mesmo tempo a
fragilidade dos sistemas que são os
sensores para as visões parciais como
mostra aí o problema de sensores é um
problema que permeia espaçonaves com
o mas por laender que foi uma espaçonave
projetada para pousar nos pólos de março
como o nome diz ou mesmo as sondas da
palha unir que foram projetadas para
vênus você pode estar se perguntando que
tem haver um problema de sensores
conosco só pra colocar um pouco demais
contexto
quando você tem uma missão espacial ea
missão está operando com acerto anomalia
e se por acaso o sensor indica essa
anomalia que pode acontecer com a missão
pode falhar colocando em risco inclusive
vidas humanas
foi um problema nos sensores que fez com
que um avião com alguns anos atrás que
ia do rio de janeiro para o país
a paris caiu no oceano atlântico
então é um problema muito crítico por
outro lado quando se tem uma contagem na
missão espacial a contagem regressiva
onde milhares de parâmetros são
analisados são avaliados e de repente
indica se que existe uma certa anomalia
para ser contagem regressiva desmonta a
unidade checa se o componente que
possivelmente seja seja a fonte do
problema e descobre que tudo funcionava
adequadamente mas o sensor falhou o que
acontece nessa situação só se perde duas
coisas tempo e dinheiro pra vencer esse
desafio os cientistas cada vez mais
trabalha com o conceito de redundância
funcional o que que é isso colocar
sistemas reservas para uma função que
precisaria de uma bomba e motor se
coloca duas ou três semanas conhecido
mas aí tem um problema que é cada quilo
que é mandado no espaço custa da ordem
de 20 mil dólares cada quilo cada lote
custa muito
e daí os cientistas também tem uma outra
abordagem que é desenvolver modelos pra
que se indica o comportamento do sistema
através de equações de modelos
matemáticos seu conceito de sensor
virtual
então esses desafios colocam uma meta
trabalhar com o sistema
cada vez mais confiáveis onde o sensor é
claramente o elo fraco da cadeia
sistêmica
mas vamos falar de três desafios eles
não são nem de longe os únicos
obviamente apenas três nós estamos
abordando aqui o próximo tem um conceito
interessante que é o conceito de tenha
escrito lá em cima terra forme terra
forma é uma área de pesquisa que estuda
como tornar os outros planetas parecidos
com a terra
só que nós temos um desafio porque
independente das missões se missoni
missões tripuladas nós vamos ter que
viver lá
o maior desafio agora é viver de forma
sustentável aqui até baseado nesse
desafio em 2007 trazendo pra vocês
informação que não sei se todos conhecem
em 2007 a nasa estabeleceu um concurso
entre todos os centros da nasa e o
objetivo desse concurso era projetar e
construir o prédio mais sustentável do
governo americano
essa informação pode ser útil para você
esse concurso foi estabelecido em 2007 e
um dos centros da nasa que o emissor
center fica na cidade de mountain view
na califórnia só pra ter idéia montam
viu é o vale do silício o coração do
vale do silício ganhou esse concurso e
se criou esse prédio é esse prédio está
construído em mountain view e foi
liberado em 2012
nesse prédio ele tem um conceito de um
laboratório vivo onde tecnologias como
gerenciamento de cargas elétricas liga
desliga automaticamente programação de
computador as luzes os equipamentos
controle de temperatura e outros são
apresentados aqui mostra se que na
concepção do prédio se estudou os tipos
de eventos que existiam na baía de são
francisco e também se estudou o conceito
de painéis solares têm mais funcionárias
nesse
inclusive em alguns momentos esse painel
e se esse prédio produz mais energia do
que consome e aqui mostra se a
recuperação de água recuperação de água
com a tecnologia trazida da estação
internacional espacial adaptada por aqui
com esse prédio a nasa tem o objetivo de
aprender ao máximo sobre
sustentabilidade
daí vem o nome sustainability base para
que aqui nós possamos ter uma vida mais
sustentável possível em todas as
atividades
esse é um prédio da atividade de
pesquisa o terceiro grande desafio sobre
o qual nós vamos conversar aqui me
colocou uma dúvida como apresentar isso
de maneira não tão seca há duas semanas
atrás eu fiz uma viagem para os estados
unidos e é justamente uma reunião neste
prédio foi na conferência são francisco
e uma reunião neste prédio e na volta eu
parei no aeroporto de hilton uma conexão
e eu falei legal me lembrei de uma frase
que vocês devem conhecer rylstone we
have a prova
se você assistiu apollo 13 conhece essa
frase a fifa se célebre como é o
terceiro desafio da nossa conversa é
transformar problemas em edições
porque se é uma coisa que você vai ter
na tecnologia espacial como qualquer
tecnologia de ponta é o aparecimento de
problemas então uma outra coisa que eu
gostaria de compartilhar com vocês é uma
iniciativa de um outro centro da nasa
chamado godah
e essa iniciativa pressupõe que você
tenha os chamados pau
após lançar chance em outras palavras
pare e aprenda sessões aonde a
organização faz com que os seus
colaboradores para as suas atividades
rotineiras pra aprender as lições
essas sessões têm alguns princípios aqui
o coloquei somente alguns princípios
para compartilhar com os senhores como o
conhecimento é compartilhado
nesse sentido o compartilhamento de
conhecimento pra eles é mais importante
do que a memória a manutenção do
conhecimento mas também estudar como as
pessoas aprendem entender como as
organizações avaliadas cada organização
tem métricas diferentes e avaliação e
sobretudo criar espaços de workshop que
possam ser livres para se trocar pela
experiência pessoal que tive trabalhando
ano na nasa posso dizer que é um dos
ambientes mais diversos que existem em
termos de pessoas de diferentes
formações mas também de diferentes
etnias e este ambiente pressupõe um
laboratório muito importante como nós
aprendemos dos demais pesquisadores e
essas orientações essas lições podem ser
útil à sua organização
daí foi escolha de compartilhar isso com
vocês aqui
em síntese nós temos esses três
problemas criar sensores ou sistemas
cada vez mais confiáveis do sensor o elo
fraco da cadeia é viver de maneira
sustentável aqui na terra e acima de
tudo aprender as lições
se você for analisar bem esses três
problemas não são somente ligados à
conquista espacial
são muito em função do que você vive
aqui na terra
então fica aqui a seguinte reflexão eu
trabalho com o software mas eu pude
perceber na experiência de trabalhar um
ano que na grande maioria das vezes e
power é muito mais importante do que
hardware e software
se você gosta de hardware software ou te
dando a dica trabalho também com o ppi
por saiba trabalhar com pessoas ea
última dica que eu gostaria de passar
através da tecnologia espacial
nós podemos realmente conceber
fisicamente que esse planeta terra é um
de fato uma certa nave espacial muito
complexa com grande biodiversidade
mas acima de tudo talvez o êxito da
conquista espacial
seja como nós podemos viver neste
planeta entendendo que a terra pode ser
sim considerada um só país e todos nós
seres humanos os seus cidadãos
muito obrigado